[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Here we are, flying above the
Monterey Bay National Marine
Sanctuary.
Spectacular view today.
We've been studying this
region for some time.
And what we've learned is that
the largest migration on earth
occurs beneath the sea here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're keeping alive a
tradition of tagging
that goes back
almost 40 years now,
to when I was a
young student working
with Dr. Frank Carey of Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institution.
Dr. Carey was
pioneering deployment
of acoustic technology
on large predatory fish
when a crisis struck
the shark world.
- Something's going
on, what's going on?
[WHISTLE BLOWING]
- Everybody out.
- It was 1975, when the
world's first summer
blockbuster was released.
"Jaws" smashed
box office records
and unleashed an
irrational terror
the idea that the only good
shark was a dead shark.
"Jaws" author, Peter
Benchley, was horrified
and became a dedicated
shark conservationist.
He joined forces with Carey on
the first scientific expedition
to study white sharks
in the Atlantic.
- This will give us
water temperature,
the depth of the fish, and
his muscle temperature.
- He's coming up to the boat,
he want to bite the boat.
- Dr. Carey believed white
shark's hunting ability,
endurance, and intense
bursts of speed
were enhanced by
being warm bodied.
- Nice place?
- Nice place, terrific.
Let's see what his
temperature is.
It's 23.2.
The water is 17
degrees, so the fish
is 23, that's a six
degree difference.
That's really warm.
- This important
revelation was followed
by a stream of
scientific firsts,
including Stan Waterman
shooting this first footage
of a white shark
below American waters.
Carey collected biological
data as the shark swam
for 110 miles over five days,
showing that electronic tagging
was the wave of the future.
Barbara Block was
Frank's technician.
She was inspired and took
Carey's pioneering science
into the future.
- Some 40 years later, with some
of the world's most advanced
technology that you can put
on an animal in the sea,
and what we're hoping
to get is a lot more
of the undersea
behavior, what's really
happening from the white
shark point of view this year.
- Shark up.
- Shark's right here.
- We really designed
this process
to be a noninvasive
tagging process,
but it requires that the
animals come close to you.
And the idea is that they
come within five or six feet
of the boat.
And that's when you
clamp that tag on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- What our entire
program is about
is figuring out how do we
really see beneath the sea
and capture what's
not very transparent?
How many sharks there are,
how many tunas there are.
And how do we
prevent the poaching
that our generation has
unleashed upon the oceans, that
will guarantee that
future generations see
these great predators.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID HELVARG: The media
is not a substitute
for social movements, but
obviously, social movements
depend on it.
It's the oxygen.
Growing communications
tools that link young people
around our blue planet
and create social movements
out of common, shared values.
These are the
moments and movements
that one waits a
lifetime to experience.
And young people in every
part of our blue ocean planet
are beginning to come
together and say,
if we just take the extractable
resources, we extract them all,
and we end up with a wasteland.
It's also a product
liability issue.
This product, oil, used as
directed, overheats our planet
and acidifies our seas.
Each of us can act
at so many levels,
as consumers, as citizens,
to really change the tide
and to become part
of something larger.
It's an opportunity.
We really can build a
kind of citizen movement
and engagement that
changes everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MICHIEL BAKKER: All righty,
good afternoon everybody.
So let's dive right in.
So maybe as a first
opening question,
whoever wants to take it.
So why should we care
about the oceans?
So what role does
oceans actually
play for us human beings?
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: Small question.
Go ahead.
Take a breath or two
and talk about it.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: Well,
it's good that you
say that, take a breath.
One of the things that
we say is about 50-80%
of the oxygen in our
atmosphere that we breathe
is as a result of the oceans.
We used to-- my career,
I started in the Amazon.
And the reason I went
to work in the Amazon
was because it was the
lungs of the planet.
And deforestation was this
massive concern at that time,
that we thought was
contributing and driving
a lot of climate change.
That's true.
But I think what we've
learned since is that the--
and just even in
the last five years,
we're learning more
and more about how
the ocean is the underpinning
for the global climate system.
We think of it as
like maybe the beating
heart of the climate system.
So it's hard to underestimate
the role of the ocean
in creating a habitable planet.
So I'll tee that up
for everyone else.
BARBARA BLOCK: Great job.
I mean, oceans literally
cover 70% of our planet.
And the oceans provide us
both with a blue economy,
that we are dependent
upon as humans,
as well as, Kyle said,
the oxygen we breathe.
We're actually jeopardizing
right now our sustainability
on this planet by putting
heat into the ocean,
putting CO2 into the sea, making
it much like a Coke warming up
on your desk.
Bubble off oxygen, that's
vital for animals in the sea,
and more corrosive because of
the absorption of CO2, which
means the gills of the sharks
and the tunas will be affected.
DAVID HELVARG: Yeah, I mean
it's respiration, recreation,
transportation, trade,
energy, protein, just
that sense of awe and wonder
when you look out to sea
and realize you're part of
something larger than yourself.
And always that sense that the
sea was too large to impact,
and yet in a blink of an
eye that's been my lifetime,
we've totally begun an
alteration of the largest
living system on the planet.
MICHIEL BAKKER: Birgitte,
any other comments?
ANA BLANCO: We're doing so
much to harm our oceans.
And we depend on it so much
like everyone has already said.
But I think one of the
most important things
is bringing awareness to how
vital and how critical it is.
And I'm hearing a lot more
people talking about the ocean,
especially with climate change.
And it's a good thing.
But there's still a
lot of work to do.
And I think it can be
done on a broad scale.
It can be done on a
legislative scale.
It can be done on
an individual scale.
So the mission is really
to get the word out.
Because it's critical and
it's vital to our survival.
MICHIEL BAKKER: So
what signals do you
see that really make
you believe that we
are at great risk for
the future of the oceans?
So are there things
that you really see,
here are the clear elements that
you should see, loud and clear,
of why we're at risk.
DAVID HELVARG: Florida
just had a red tide,
of harmful algal bloom that
killed hundreds of manatees,
thousands of marine
mammals, billions of fish,
and created harmful
impacts for human health.
People were actually
coughing and getting sick.
That was on the Gulf
Coast of Florida.
At the same time, you
had your green-blue algae
repeating on the
east coast, which
is called green gunk by the
locals, destroying the economy,
threatening society.
And globally, we're
seeing increase
of these harmful algal blooms.
It's just one of the indicators
of a sick ocean, when what
we need is a healthy ocean.
BIRGITTE RASINE: And The other
one is also coral bleaching.
I mean, that's been on
an exponential increase
unfortunately.
And that's like the
canary in the gold mine.
DAVID HELVARG: And this is the
largest living system on earth
that you can see from space,
the Great Barrier Reef.
And we're seeing, if you get a
chance to see "Chasing Coral,"
it's a good documentary film.
We wouldn't show it.
Ana's Ocean Film Fest introduced
our March for the Ocean
in June.
And we decided that we
wouldn't show certain films
like "Chasing Coral"
because I didn't
want people crying while
we were marching for power.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: I would
say, one of the things,
we know so little
about the ocean.
And that's increasing
with all the technology,
and the sensors, and the
capability we have to explore.
The problem of ocean plastic
has gotten a lot of attention
in the press.
We've often been wondering
about that as ocean scientists,
because we're like,
we've been talking
about climate change,
which is literally melting
the planet, for decades.
And this has not gotten as much
attention as ocean plastic.
But what I can tell you
is that most of what
we know about the ocean,
we know about the surface.
If you heard Barb
in that first clip,
she showed one of the
fascinating things
about these electronic
tags is they tell us
about the real lives
of tuna and sharks,
that are traveling
all sorts of places
that we've never really been.
One of the things we've
learned about plastic
in the ocean, which through
our work with the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Research Institute, is
that most of the microplastic
that's in the ocean is
far below the surface.
It's several hundred meters
below the surface, about four
times the surface level.
And everywhere we
looked, we found plastic.
We found it at the
deepest places.
surface, obviously.
But everything that
you pretty much
know about ocean
microplastic is from studies
done at the surface, which
is an accessible place.
And what we learn, the further
deep, the farthest we go,
is that it's everywhere.
And so one of the
alarming things for us
is that, if you thought
microplastic in the ocean
was a problem, it's a
lot worse of a problem
than you probably knew.
Because the further you go,
the further deep you go,
the more you find.
DAVID HELVARG: What you
don't want with technology
for observation
is you don't want
to have real time digital
imagery of ecosystem
in collapse.
So when you use good technology
for fisheries enforcement,
as Google is working on,
when you use it for tracking
and science, as Barbara's
doing, developing
those kind of applications
that bring engineers together
with biologists, as MBARI
does, then hopefully,
and in places like California,
the discoveries then,
the science actually
gets applied to policy.
Unfortunately, that's not true
at the present time in DC,
where even the basic
science is denied.
But I think we have a
moment with the technology
that we can transform
it into policy
with enough popular will.
And we'll talk about that.
BARBARA BLOCK: I
think what we have
to think about is
as a scientist,
we're asking some really
big picture questions.
What is Earth going to
look like without ice caps?
What is the
consequence of melting
our polar and Antarctic caps?
What is going it to do in terms
of submergence, ocean currents
changing, the entire
biosphere that we live on,
Earth, becoming different?
We're in the sixth
mass extinction.
So how many of you
like to eat sushi here?
You can admit it.
I see hands going up.
Brian, of course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
was up too.
BARBARA BLOCK:
Yeah, the capacity
of humans to eat our way through
both land and sea is enormous.
So we're actually destroying
our ocean environment
by not being sustainable
about what we eat.
Sushi, Poke, all those
type of restaurants
are contributing
to this problem,
killing not only tunas,
but killing sharks,
and sea turtles, and seabirds.
I think that there's hope, in
the sense that we have places
like Google, which are using
their tremendous resources
right now, not only
to do searches that
help us understand
what we're looking for,
but also creating
transparency in the ocean
through Google Oceans
and Global Fish Watch,
creating a capacity to now
see where humans are impacting
the planet in a way that we've
never been able to see before.
So we're able to turn
on the light switch
and see where humans are.
And if we can use
big data crunching
combining fish and ships
as well as fish and chips,
we'll be able to
potentially get our hands
on some of these problems.
DAVID HELVARG: And I think
with my background 30 years
as a journalist, I
can't be eco-optimist,
but what I do say is, we're
now at this stage of triage.
That we're going to save
what we can while we can.
The IPCC report in
2018 says that if we
can keep temperatures
to 1.5 degrees Celsius,
we can save perhaps 10% of
our living coral reef systems.
If it goes over two
degrees, we lose it.
And so, with existential
threats like this,
we need big responses.
I mean, right now I'm
working on the Blue New
Deal, the ocean
and coastal aspects
that we want to integrate.
And I'm going back
east to DC on Wednesday
to talk to the people who
introduced the Green New
Deal, which is a great concept.
By the time there's hopefully
a change in government,
and we hit the road, hit the
ground running in January 2021,
with real legislation to really
do the transition that science
tells us we have to.
ANA BLANCO: And
then to add to that,
I think we're very well-versed
and knowledgeable about what's
happening in the ocean,
and really appreciate
this opportunity to
share what we know.
And one thing that
keeps popping up
that I'm reading
a lot more about
is the increase in population.
Because, we as humans,
are the ones that
are doing most of the damage.
And we are the ones that
need to be educated.
But with the increase
in population, and just
it's taking its toll
on the finite resources
that this planet has to offer.
So I think that is
another component that
plays into all of
this, that we need
to start talking about as well.
MICHIEL BAKKER: You are
the experts in this field.
As a layperson on
the outside, what
do you think we should know
being the three largest
challenges we're faced
with with the oceans?
I know there are more.
But if you would say, if we
could only fix the first three,
what would those first three be?
ANA BLANCO: Should we
huddle first, and then
decide which ones we want--
BIRGITTE RASINE: I think
that one thing that we
have to fix, or not fix,
but actually establish
is a relationship
between us and the ocean.
I think, Kyle, you brought
up the point of how
come we didn't really
have so much pickup
in the media about
climate change,
and now plastic pollution?
Well, the reason is because
every one of us uses plastic.
It's something that-- it's
our children's birthday toys.
It's our plastic knives.
It's lots of--
chairs in this room.
So unless and until we can
start connecting those dots
and make it very
personal, something
that we care-- because
what do people care about?
They care about their health.
They care about their
finances, our children,
things that are near
and dear to us, right?
So we have to find those
things that make the ocean near
and dear to us.
So that would be--
DAVID HELVARG: Not
three, but when
I wrote "50 Ways
to Save the Ocean,"
number one is go to
the beach, because you
protect what you love.
And I think that's why
things work in California,
because Californians have
the sense of entitlement
to the beach and ocean,
because we have the access.
BARBARA BLOCK: I think we
have to eat sustainably.
So we've got to figure
out what that means,
both on land and sea.
And when you see that brand new
Poke restaurant down street,
start asking the question,
when you put a piece of tuna
in your mouth, where
did that tuna come from?
We don't put beef in
our mouth and do it
without knowing where's this
beef from, what type of animal
is it.
And yet, we do this with
ocean food all the time.
So I want everyone
to take a moment
and think about what
is it I'm eating.
And has it been
caught sustainably?
Is it something I
should be eating?
And what kind of waters
did it come out of?
DAVID HELVARG: I was at
the Our Ocean Conference
that John Kerry put on when
he was Secretary of State.
Sylvia Earle came late
to the lunch table.
And there's just one
tray left with sort
of fillets labeled fish.
She goes what kind of fish?
I go, oh, there's the
Assistant Secretary of State,
let's go ask her.
Drag her over,
and she goes, um--
Sylvia's like,
it's labeled fish.
She goes, well, I
asked the caterers
to make sure it was sustainable.
She says, but it's labeled fish.
The chicken's not labeled bird.
BARBARA BLOCK: [LAUGHS] The
chicken's not labeled bird.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: I think
what everyone's said
is obviously important.
Climate change, I think
we probably agree,
is the number one threat facing
the ocean and the planet.
Sustainable fishing is
absolutely up there.
And I think that just from a
sheer scientific standpoint,
I would say marine
pollution, and sewage,
and plastic as part of that,
has got to be up there.
And Aldo Leopold
said that we love--
we grow to love
what we understand.
And by engaging California--
I mean, I'm not from California.
But one of the fascinating
things about coming here
a couple of decades ago is
that the dream of California
seems to me, the coexistence
of relatively pristine nature
and the most advanced
technological society
that we have right
here in the Bay Area.
We have this
wonderful open space.
And we didn't have
that by accident.
We had that on purpose,
because people loved
the open space and the coast.
And we have this California
Coastal Commission
who vehemently defends that.
And that is the essence of
like Surfrider Foundation
and organizations like that.
I'm a surfer.
I don't surf on
certain days, because I
don't want the pollution in the
water, to get sick from that.
And just engaging and
taking care of the place
where you are, I think,
is absolutely critical.
DAVID HELVARG: And when I
wrote "The Golden Shore,
California's Love Affair
with the Sea," which
I won't flash up here.
But basically, I'd been in DC
nine years, and I came home.
And a lot of what we did
with Blue Frontiers, how
do we scale up
solutions in time.
And I realized, California
is a solution at scale.
We're 40 million people.
We're the world's
fifth largest economy.
And we do pretty good
with our coast and ocean,
because there's that
sense of entitlement.
And I also think there's this
democracy of blue interest,
because you have
conservationists, and surfers,
and fishermen, and the
Navy, and the ports,
and all these different
interests that value.
And when you do
right by the ocean,
you find out it does
good by your economy
and everything else.
Ask yourself this question.
To Barbara and to
Richard as well.
So this notion of does what I
eat really make a difference,
and does one person
really make a difference.
So when you talk about
knowing what you eat,
sushi, poke, you
it might be, how
would you deal with
an individual's
who's going to pose you the
question, my individual actions
don't really make a
difference, because I'm one
of know seven billion people.
How do you ultimately
touch that individual,
and make him or her believe
that his or her actions do
make a difference?
BIRGITTE RASINE: Well, I
would say that you're not
just one person.
You're one of seven billion.
So the more of us
that think like that,
it's going to be seven billion
people thinking like this.
BARBARA BLOCK: I agree.
I mean, we've lost
our connection
to the natural world.
It's happening
all the time as we
evolve on this planet
as a human species.
I think that the more that we
can understand that individuals
make a difference
through both education,
such as the aquarium, or through
youth programs, connecting
humans to the sea, humans
to the land, the better
off this planet will be.
Because that's what we've
lost across the globe.
And the more we interact
with technology,
the less we interact
with the world around us.
BIRGITTE RASINE: And that's
why like, you guys know
that Instagram egg?
How many of you have seen that?
The one that garnered more, like
the most Instagram likes ever.
And so I think, well, if I
were that one person liking
that egg, I could have said,
well, I'm just one person.
I'm not going to make a change
in how many likes this egg has.
And yet, we've got 35 or
50 million likes, right?
So we've just got to
find that thing that
makes us hit like on the ocean.
DAVID HELVARG: In French, they
say that one egg is enough.
But it's really, it's
this false dichotomy.
I can't help myself.
People say, well, is it the
personal or the political?
And it's like saying do you quit
smoking or fight big tobacco?
I mean, I don't eat sushi.
And then we had a
healthy ocean hill day
where we lobbied and helped
pass an IUU pirate fishing bill,
so that we don't
deplete the ocean.
I mean, your individual
acts, the things you do,
inspire you to engage
with the larger world.
MICHIEL BAKKER: So how do
you engage your audience?
So how do you get
people actually excited
about your world versus
so many other worlds
that are screaming for attention
and for activism as well?
Maybe, for you, David.
DAVID HELVARG: Start
with people who
love the ocean, who
live by the ocean.
We try and build a constituency.
We bring every two
years, except this year,
because it's useless.
Bring people together in
DC from around the ocean,
connect Maritime
conservationists
with Maritime communities.
Realize they have allies in
places like big institutions,
like the Monterey Aquarium,
the National Aquarium.
That they have allies with the
Commandant of the Coast Guard,
or with Senators
Whitehouse or Markey.
And go on the Hill.
We've had Healthy
Ocean Hill Days,
where we've had 26
state delegations,
and the third biggest
was from Colorado,
because in April, we're going
to have an inland ocean Action
Summit in Dallas.
And we're going to try and
grow the inland ocean movement,
and make people realize every
state's a coastal state.
You connect up.
It starts, like I say,
number one's go to the beach.
It starts with people who
love, and care, and depend
for their livelihoods
on the ocean.
And then you just try
and do whatever you can,
and use whatever tools you
have, to connect with people.
Tools like the International
Ocean Film Festival
and the tools of science.
And make science
exciting, the way Barbara
gets to commune with
great white sharks.
And one of the
things in California
is, we're not afraid.
There's a sense
that if there's not
something bigger and
meaner than you out there,
it's not really wilderness.
And I think that just
making those connections.
I always talk about
our job in the US
is to restore the blue and
our red, white, and blue.
It's patriotic not to
pollute our living seas.
ANA BLANCO: And I
want to add to that.
I actually went with
David to Washington, DC,
for one of his Blue
Vision Summits.
I can't remember how many
years ago it was now.
But there were so many people
from all over the country.
And we had the opportunity
to meet with our legislators.
And we were discussing the
ocean policy back then.
And we had three things that
we wanted to talk about.
And it was my first time,
actually, being on the Hill.
And actually being able
to talk to my legislators.
And I was so impressed
with the impact
that we had as a group, coming
from across the United States,
and having a voice, and
communicating our interests
and what we needed.
So getting people together and
getting that voice out there
is what David does.
And we do it with the
film festival as well.
So we provide a
platform for people
to come together and
talk about the ocean.
And we show films
from around the world.
And film is incredibly
powerful for telling a message,
whether it's a 30-second PSA.
The "Blue Serengeti"
film that we showed,
Barbara's film that we showed,
and had a wonderful panel
discussion about
that afterwards.
DAVID HELVARG: Well, when and
where might you be doing this?
ANA BLANCO: Thanks, David.
The festival is coming
up in March 7 through 10.
And it's at Cowell
Theater in San Francisco.
So it's really an
opportunity for us
to raise awareness
about the ocean.
And there's something
for everyone,
in terms of the myriad
topics that we cover.
Because there's so many
issues in the ocean that
need to be talked about, not
only climate change, sea level
rising, overfishing, mining,
drilling, sand dredging,
marine wildlife.
But we also show films that are
how we engage with the ocean,
and appreciate it, and have
fun with it, from surfing,
and sailing, and the
joy that it brings us,
and the peace and tranquility
that it brings us,
which is all the more
reason to protect it.
But again, it's just like David
said, bringing people together
who are like minded, who
have a common interest
and want to do something.
And until you learn
about what you can do,
you're kind of at a
loss, so to speak.
And so the films,
and David's Summit,
it's really just a
matter of getting engaged
and finding out what's out
there and what's available.
DAVID HELVARG: And last June
9th, Ana brought the film
fest the night before, in DC.
We had a first ever
march for the ocean.
And the anchor march in DC
was only like 3,000 people,
but there were 114 other marches
that happened around the world.
And we discovered that there's
this whole youthful cohort,
this sort of year class
of 10 to 18-year-olds,
who are very engaged
round plastic.
And so the Dublin march,
and 11-year-old activists
led 500 people in Dublin.
And out in the Pacific, there
was a 12 and a 16-year-old
who organized that Chamorro
was on their island that
then got hit by a typhoon
three months later.
So people are-- and
we'll do it again
on World Oceans Day, June 8th.
But people are marching
for something that's
immediately on top of them.
I mean, what we saw with the
hurricane season of 2017,
and then the climate
impacts with--
I mean, I think 2018
was sort of the year
of no denial between
Mexico Beach, Florida,
and Paradise, California.
And the ocean's the driver
of climate and weather,
and takes it 90% of the
heat that we put out there.
So it's key.
Any climate solution has to
also be an ocean solution.
BARBARA BLOCK: I mean,
there's another aspect
that we have to think about
that maybe someone in the Google
environment can help us with.
We're hunters and gatherers.
And I ask my
students at Stanford
all the time, how many are
planning your dinner a week
from now?
Anybody?
I see one hand, one
hand in the audience.
So how can we as a
species, that's really
been focused on a very
short-term future,
how do we get people to
worry about something
that's going to be a disaster
less than 30 to 50 years away.
And that's the challenge we
face as a species worldwide.
And I think about this a lot.
MICHIEL BAKKER: So maybe
just building upon this.
So I believe that all of you
know extraordinarily well what
the challenges are we're
faced with with the oceans.
You probably have
clarity as well
about what needs to get done.
So maybe for the
audience, if you
were in control, if you
had your magical wands,
what three elements
would you do?
And how would you go about?
So to me, it's a
question of what
needs to get done,
but at the same time,
how do you get it done
in today's very polarized
environment?
BARBARA BLOCK: I'll start.
I'm a researcher.
And I get flabbergasted
at how small
amount of money that is needed
right now to do some major push
forward in our ocean knowledge.
So imagine a planet
where we haven't really
explored the entire planet.
We've got new technology in
DNA technology, bioinformatics,
that allows us to
actually go in, take
a Ziploc full of water,
and figure out who swam by.
So we need to develop
these types of technologies
to better census our oceans.
We've got companies
across the planet that
are able to manage
data, like Google,
and do an outstanding job of
bringing together big data.
Right now, there's not
a big data platform
for the oceans that
combines information
in a way that makes it
accessible to both scientists
and the public.
We need that big data
platform for our oceans
as soon as possible.
We need to develop
sensors, sensors
that allow us to know
how the oxygen is
changing in the ocean, how the
pH is changing in the ocean.
And we need to have
these tomorrow.
And they need to be cheap.
And they need to be everywhere.
So we have this
sort of bio-sensor
in the planet telling us what's
happening before it's too late.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN:
Just to jump on that.
Having automated
networked sensors,
taking the research
that we do and applying
the Internet of Things to it,
is desperately what we need.
We just recently-- I'm
a researcher as well,
and we just recently
put together
an analysis which is in
review right now, which
is, in our view, is the
first ever global map
of where all species
are on the planet,
in land and in the ocean.
Usually, when you see
something like this,
you see a picture of the land.
And then the ocean
is grayed out.
Or you see the picture of the
ocean, and land is grayed out.
And what we've done, because
of data availability,
is we've been able to
bring together something
like 100,000 different species
and their distribution.
And then, crucially, not just
say this is where they are,
but use all the available
environmental data
to explain why those
species are where they are.
Now this is a first step.
This is, historically, this has
been a question for scientists
for hundreds of years.
But we've just had to
make progress iteratively
by focusing on
certain species we
know, like birds in certain
places, like South America.
But we don't have to limit
ourselves that way any more.
We can integrate everything,
like Barb's saying.
But we certainly need the
data streams, the satellites,
and to do that.
Barb mentioned
environmental DNA,
like having a
Ziploc bag of water.
We're just about to install
essentially a robot,
but it's a 50 gallon drum.
And we're putting this in a
stream on the California coast
to count salmon as they go by
and using environmental DNA
to do that.
This is revolutionary
technology that we desperately
need to put on mobile
autonomous platforms and survey
to the places that aren't
so near to the coast.
Now we could send divers to
snorkel these streams and count
fish.
But wouldn't it be a lot easier
just to put a sensor in there
and do that?
And that's where
we are right now,
the technology that we can have.
And we're just starting to
scratch the surface with this.
DAVID HELVARG: In a sense,
space technology's easy.
There's a vacuum up there
and some micro meteorites.
You know, the ocean is
this unbreathable corrosive
liquid medium, with
upwellings, and surges,
and storms, inaccessible,
biologicals,
and all these challenges.
We're reaching
that technology now
and the media to actually
make the vast, everlasting sea
accessible to us.
But we're reaching it right
at that critical moment,
where we're facing an
existential threat.
And in the last century, we
faced two, the rise of fascism
in the nuclear
balance of terror.
And we got past them.
Right now, because
of what Barbara
said, because we don't
respond to long-term threats,
we're seeing that it's
all foreshortened.
And we're seeing the
threats in real time now.
And so we need big,
dramatic responses.
We need to respond to the
threat of climate change,
and marine pollution, and
loss of habitat at the level--
I live in Richmond Marina.
My sailboat marina's where
they had Kaiser Shipyard Number
Two, where they built 734
Liberty Ships in four years.
So that kind of
industrial mobilization,
the Manhattan Project, is
what we need right now.
And what this new wave of young
women coming into Congress
is proposing with
a Green New Deal.
So we have to take all of
science, all the technology.
And quite frankly, if
you look at our economy,
we've got three major
sectors, sort of.
The financial sector that
crashed the world economy
in 2008.
We've got the oil and gas
industry, the fossil fuel
industry, that's literally
crashing the world.
And then the tech
industry, based
in California, which for
all the problems you've got,
is producing goods and services
with technological capability
to understand threats.
And now we need to mobilize
large parts of our population
to respond to those threats.
We did it twice in
the last century.
We'll do something in this one.
MICHIEL BAKKER: Birgitte or
Ana, any additional thoughts
from you?
BIRGITTE RASINE: Yes, some
years ago, I wrote a report
on responsibility in the media.
And I actually got to interview
Andy Rifkin of "The New York
Times."
He's a top scientist,
science reporter.
And I asked him, because
I was at the time
working on climate change.
And I asked him
why is it that we
find we find it so
hard to understand
and kind of embody in
ourselves an understanding
of climate change?
And he said, it's very simple.
We don't teach our young
people how to think critically.
We do not teach at the
elementary school level
or up until you, basically
until you get to university,
we don't teach basic scientific
understanding and thinking.
He said, if we can-- so if I
had my magic wand, I would do--
can I have two magic wands?
I would do two things.
I wouldn't first introduce a
study of maybe scuba diving
as a required curriculum in
coastal states, something
like that.
We need to bring it
down to that level.
And second, popular culture.
Popular culture, like can we
have a Blue Panther movie?
Can we have Coral Sponge Bob,
or coral whatever his name is?
So I think we need
to tell more stories.
DAVID HELVARG: Carl Coral.
BIRGITTE RASINE: What?
BIRGITTE RASINE: There
you go, Carl Coral.
Hollywood, you listening?
So I think we need
to tell more stories.
And I don't mean kind
of didactic, beat them
over the head
about, maybe there's
a movie about coral bleaching or
something like that, not that.
But somehow find
stories that take
the mythology and the
fascination with the ocean,
because God knows, you
go down deep enough
and it's all science
fiction down there.
BARBARA BLOCK: You're
raising a great issue.
It's one that just Friday we
were discussing at Stanford.
So there really is an
ocean literacy problem.
I'm working on a
project right now trying
to think about at
the collegiate level
how to bring about
ocean literacy.
We also are working
with Aspen High Seas,
trying to figure out if we could
do an ocean conservation corps.
So what if there
was a way to get
youth engaged at a very
early age, that was global.
So I think that we've done a
lot of that in our land ethic.
But we've done a
little less, because
of its inaccessibility,
the high seas,
places like that, for oceans.
But it really begins
at the basic problem
of teaching how oceans work.
So if you went down the
street in a beautiful place
like Monterey, and I asked
four individuals, well,
what's the basic concept of
how oceans and atmosphere
or oceans, and
climate, or even just
oceans, what do you think
about how they work?
And I don't think we'd get very
clear answers, because we leave
it out of our basic education.
We leave biosphere
out of our education.
So what we're thinking
about at our university is,
how do we get it back in?
And how do we make it so
accessible that a business
student, an English major,
or anybody who wants
to learn about the planet.
We do it right now through a
course called Stanford at Sea.
It's related to Sea Education
Association of Woods Hole.
These are opportunities for
high school, college students
to actually have an
immersion experience.
But we need more people to
engage in that immersion.
ANA BLANCO: And along those
lines, at the festival,
like when you mentioned
that, Barbara, you just
made me think.
Ocean literacy is
kind of a new concept.
And it's not introduced in
middle school or high school
level.
And it's such an important
part of our education.
And I think it's becoming more
and more critical to reach kids
at that particular age.
And like you said, it needs
to be on a global level.
At the festival, we do a free
program for middle school
and high school students to
come and see the films for free.
And so many of the teachers
are so excited about it,
because they just don't have
the time or the bandwidth
to include something like ocean
literacy in their program.
So they use the films
as an opportunity
to get the kids
excited about that.
We also have a student
film competition.
Kids all over the world send in
a film, five minutes or less,
that tell us about the ocean.
We use the Monterey Bay
Aquarium, has great career
online for ocean literacy.
But I don't think
we can stress enough
how much we need to start
engaging really young kids,
at the middle school
and high school level,
to start thinking about this
and make it a part of our core
curriculum.
DAVID HELVARG: And
one of our projects,
Blue Frontier
projects in this year,
2019, is a Blue
Beat program, which
is just basic idea that the
only resource not fully explored
in the ocean is
good storytelling.
And to do media
trainings for scientists,
like we've done at IUCN.
Also just grassroots
activists, to understand
how to talk to a journalists,
how to tell stories,
how to use the tools
at hand, our phones
and otherwise, to produce.
Not to do campaigns,
to tell stories.
Because that's what
connects with people.
And it's instinctual
with our young activists,
they're all using those tools.
But it's a challenge.
I want to translate "50 Ways
to Save the Ocean," to Spanish,
as one of the immediate needs.
So it's not Carl,
it's Carlos the Coral.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN:
The storytelling
is absolutely critical.
I mean, I'm a
researcher at heart,
but I try to be, I
try to tell stories.
And anything from the "Book
of Jonah" to "Moby Dick,"
the ocean has captivated our
imagination for millennia.
And obviously, it's our goal at
the aquarium to inspire people
about the ocean.
We get about two
million visitors a year.
And most of them,
geographically,
or because of their own
physical limitations,
cannot actually
go into the ocean.
They're from Kansas.
Or they have
physical limitations.
And so one of the
amazing things for us
is to see the transformation
that people have
when they go in the
door to when they leave.
And yesterday, two days
ago, Saturday morning,
I was speaking to a hundred
elementary and middle school
science teachers in the
State of California.
And everything that we've
been saying right here,
we just need to inculcate
these ideas into curriculum
in public schools.
So that is not
like an exception,
but it is the norm, that people
have a first-hand experience
of the ocean and what it is,
as well as strong curriculum
in math and science.
It absolutely has to happen.
DAVID HELVARG: And I
apologize, I was, I think,
insulting your sea
otters earlier.
But we're sort of
unique in California.
We've got these two apex marine
predators, white sharks and sea
otters, that are vital
for the environment.
And it's one of the only places
where one apex predator will
occasionally eat the other.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: Bite the other.
BARBARA BLOCK: It
probably happens more
than you think in the ocean.
MICHIEL BAKKER: All right, I
have one more hopeful question.
And that we'll open up
the room for our Q&A,
as well as the Dory.
So let's maybe end
on a hopeful note.
Are there around
the world societies
that you believe are
really getting it,
and where actually society,
a combination of governments,
local groups, are
actually taking action?
DAVID HELVARG: California,
Portugal, Palau.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: I think
we hit on something earlier
when we said, we are
in a very ideal place.
California is not normal with
respect to the United States.
I think that we are
leading the charge
in a lot of ways with
environmental legislation
and preservation,
especially with the ocean.
Our Marine Life Protection Act,
the Monterey Bay Fair Lawns
Natural Marine
Sanctuaries, these
don't exist in a lot of
places around the country.
So we're very fortunate.
I think we need to replicate
the California model
in other places.
MICHIEL BAKKER: All right,
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Given the volume
of plastic currently produced
in the world, which is about
300 million tons per year,
since the 1950s, it
just went exponentially,
I heard that it's probably
going to double by 2050.
So has anyone kind of
modeled out what an ocean's
going to look like in 2050?
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: I'll
jump on that one,
because we've been
looking at this question.
So if you remember, one of
the first scientific sort
of pieces of
information which led
to our understanding
of climate change
was Charles Keeling's
CO2 curve from the top
of Mount Aloha in Hawaii.
And that showed the
oscillating annual atmospheric
concentration of CO2.
And it wasn't just
seasonally moving around,
it was trending upwards.
That started about 1958.
And I think that was a very
important piece of science
that led us to say, wait a
second, this is a problem.
We don't have that
right now for plastic.
We don't have a Keeling Curve.
We're working on
understanding that.
But one of the things
that we toss around
is, with respect
to climate change,
if we could magically turn off
the spigot of carbon dioxide
and greenhouse gas
equivalents, we'd
probably be dealing with climate
change for about 1,000 years,
just because of how convoluted
the earth's climate system is.
If we could magically turn
off the spigot for plastic,
how much longer would we
have plastic in the ocean?
I think it's far less,
probably around 50 years.
So I'm much more
hopeful about the change
that we can make with plastic.
Yes, you are correct
that we are--
and by the way, the plastic
and the climate problem
are not unrelated.
Because plastic is made
out of petrochemicals.
So it is an oil based,
for the most part.
There is a recycled and there
is agricultural based products.
But probably around 50 years,
if we could cut it off today.
But there's more and more
going into the ocean.
So it's clearly a very
significant problem.
But we don't yet know how
big a problem that is.
We need that Keeling Curve.
DAVID HELVARG: But they're
all linked to rock oil.
They're all linked to petroleum.
The off shore
drilling, the plastics,
the protection of
our shores at risk.
We just need to move on.
I mean coal and oil were
great energy systems
for the 16th and 19th century.
Now it's, as I said,
it's a product liability,
used as directed it
spoils everything.
So let's move on and
do what we did after--
when Rockwell replaced whale
oil, the economy expanded.
With the Green New Deal,
it's going to expand again.
We'll have jobs and clean
future if we choose to.
BIRGITTE RASINE: And there's an
upstream and downstream problem
too.
So it's how much plastic
are we producing?
From what I understand, some
of the big plastic producers,
all the single use cups, and
tubs, and all that stuff,
apparently they want to produce
more, which is a big problem.
And on the other side is,
let's clean up what we've got.
So you guys probably heard
of Boyan Slat and System 001.
So he's trying right now to
clean up the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch.
And there's controversy,
meaning, well,
why are you focusing
on that when
you should be focusing on
upstream and the manufacturer?
I think we really
need to do both.
Because you need-- it's like
you've messed up your room.
Well, you've got to
clean up your room
and then see if you can find
more sustainable toys to fill
it with.
MICHIEL BAKKER: One
question from the Dory.
When it comes to
sensing ocean data,
can you talk a little
about the difference
in data needed in comparison to
what we can measure with Earth
observation satellites?
What is the role of EO
satellites in building
our understanding of the ocean?
BARBARA BLOCK: So the
Earth's satellite system
has done a fantastic
job of telling us
about the skin of the
ocean, the surface.
But the volume of the
ocean is much larger.
And so we know a lot about
the top portion of the ocean,
but we don't know a
lot about the depths.
And part of the mystery
of Earth's circulation
is that without knowing the
conditions beneath the sea,
and by not having a complete
sensor system on the planet,
we have surprises that
are going to happen.
So I believe that it'll
be in this next 50 years
that we do a very remarkable
job of instrumenting
the oceans, which has been
behind the rest of the planet.
And we're going to do it
with cheap, small sensors,
that we have to figure out how
to seed the ocean currents,
without creating, if
you will, pollution.
We're going to do it with a
series of buoys, and gliders,
and all sorts of instrumentation
we could only imagine.
And we're going to need
big data companies who
are committed to
making it public data,
being behind these efforts,
and then contributing
to this incredible analysis
that has to happen,
that will increase our
understanding of our planet.
AUDIENCE: I'll just build on,
because the original question
was about earth
observation data.
And so that's kind of
traditional satellites
in that way.
And I think in the
last five years,
we're doing things
that were impossible
seven years ago in that way.
And so a lot of what we're
doing with satellites
at sea, ship positions,
such as with Fishing
Watch and emissions that are
coming off of sulfur plumes,
we're doing air
quality measurements
from those large cargo vessels,
that's all available now.
And now the next thing is
a lot of the public radar
systems that are available.
We're measuring all the dark
fleets that aren't broadcasting
and things like that.
So that continues to evolve.
But I was curious,
Barbara, you had said,
what you really want is a big
data system for the ocean.
Are there big data systems
for the land that you think
are great models?
Or other ones that
we could really
look to, to say, well how do
we take that for the ocean?
BARBARA BLOCK: Good
question, tough one, Brian.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
something else right
after that, though I wasn't
familiar with the name of it.
BARBARA BLOCK: But
I think you want
to keep in mind that when we
say fish and ships or fish
and chips, what we
really want to do
is bring these big
data sets together.
So what we need to do
is in a public forum,
where it's not being
monopolized by a company,
to be sold back to us.
There's a little bit of
that going on in the world
right now.
So what we need, I
want to just emphasize
that, one of the more important
papers in ocean science
came out last week in
"Science," by a Duke team.
It was about really
basic aspects
of how the Atlantic
circulates and creates
what we call the bottom order
that's critical for pushing
the system.
And it isn't working like
we think it's working.
And they found that out
by seeding the ocean
with buoys that we're
able to go very deep
and then come back
to the surface
and transmit their data.
So what do we really need
to solve on planet Earth?
Communications across the globe.
One of the challenges
we have in sending
ocean data, working
sensors in the ocean, is we
don't have the ability right
now in the 21st century
to communicate from
everywhere on the planet.
Solving that
communication problem
is the key to solving,
in part, getting
some of these
sensors in place that
will tell us about the planet.
So we need to take
some of the economy
that we're spending
across this planet
and put it towards increasing
our knowledge of earth.
And as soon as we
do that, we'll be
stepping towards our future
in a positive direction.
DAVID HELVARG:
Yeah, like Thursday,
I'll be in DC covering the AAAS,
that's the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
Biggest science
gathering on earth.
And if you question whether
scientists and nerds,
they have it every year
on Valentine's Day.
BARBARA BLOCK: That's
right, they do.
DAVID HELVARG: But
it's interesting to see
this contrast of
this great excitement
with the hard scientists and
the natural scientists are like
ready to slit their wrists.
And I think that taking
those hard scientists
and hard sciences that involve
data gathering and big data
and all, and putting the
natural scientist in charge,
or having the access to use them
to identify these challenges.
BARBARA BLOCK: As long as
they're not eating sushi
while they're doing it.
MICHIEL BAKKER: What's one thing
you think Google is doing wrong
that's harming the oceans?
What can we do differently?
We like feedback.
KYLE VAN HOUTAN: Well, I will
say that Google Earth has
been transformative.
And I'd like more of that.
I think even they started
off with just basic imagery.
And then they started with
time series of imagery.
And then you could download it,
and then with added features.
I think that has been
transformative for people,
especially the user interface.
And I think providing
more platforms
for large data sharing,
like Barbara's has
been talking about is actually
critical, Local Fishing Watch.
One of my favorite
websites is called
Null School, which is
just a visualization
of environmental data, like
wind and real time temperature.
It's amazing, if you
guys have seen it.
We just need more
tools like this
and make them accessible for
non-technical data people, that
can use them in
intuitive formats.
BARBARA BLOCK: Yeah, shout out
to our Google Oceans friends.
They are a small unit
here that basically
have done more for the
oceans in the last decade
than people realize.
So we really need more of
that type of quality effort
that is inviting the
community from the globe
to sit down with them and create
the type of databases and data
sets that are distributed
publicly that we
need to improve our planet.
DAVID HELVARG: And I'll
just second or third that,
to say we gave one of our
Peter Benchley Ocean Awards
to Google Ocean early on.
And we're seeing an evolution.
And I'm just hoping, if Silicon
Valley could get it as excited
about using it its capabilities
to save the living salty heart
of the planet as they are
about self-driving cars,
then I'd be really--
so more of the same,
is what we'd say.
And on a larger scale.
Scale it up to the challenge.
ANA BLANCO: So maybe more of
that and less Google buses
maybe, on the roads.
MICHIEL BAKKER: All
right, before we close,
anything from you?
BIRGITTE RASINE: I say more
Google Doodles about the ocean.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We'd been planning for this
voyage for over three years.
I've been thinking about
it for over a decade.
And would we're going to
do is depart from Honolulu
for the white shark cafe.
This is a place, the
only way we know about it
is white sharks took us there.
And in this region,
there's a gathering place.
And why these animals
gather here, we don't know.
- I mean all of us out here
are incredibly excited.
And this white shark cafe is one
of those last real expeditions.
We know very little about it.
We have no idea about why this
massive predator is leaving
California and coming here.
- There must be something
so important here.
Part of this is about
discovering what's in the ocean
and the white sharks
are leading us there.
- Why do the sharks come out to
this remote part of the ocean?
One of the ways we approach
answering that question
is to characterize the habitat.
And we've put together a
variety of tools and approaches
to let us do that.
What are the conditions
in the water column
itself, temperature,
oxygen, salinity?
We're going to be sending sound
waves into the water column
to see what reflections
of that sound
tell us about the concentrations
of animals versus depths.
We're using EDNA to tell us how
different species of animals
occupy this space.
- We got some white shark hits.
- Yeah, we got [INAUDIBLE].
- What's the breaking news here?
- Breaking news, yeah.
- Oh, my god.
The first try.
- The first try.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- We've been using the
sail drones as scouts.
The sail drones have been
out here surveying the region
in advance of our arrival.
And they will continue to
survey it while we're here.
And they can alert
to things that
may be just over the horizon.
- It communicates to us
a lot of the sensor data.
We get summaries to give us
an idea, for example, where
we should be sampling
on this vessel,
based on what the
sail drones have seen.
- For me there's no substitute
for direct observation
I want to see what's there.
And if I can't go down myself,
then the best thing to use
is an underwater vehicle, a
remotely operated vehicle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [INAUDIBLE] 182.
- 182, it's right here, guys.
It's in visual
range, right here.
- [INAUDIBLE] 182, [INAUDIBLE].
- Yeah, bridge, I might
have eyes on it here.
About 100 meters going straight.
- And we're now recovering
each of these instruments
as it comes up.
When we get the tag
back, it has second
by second behavioral data
and environmental data
on what the white sharks do.
- Nice one, mate.
- Great.
- It's a female.
It's been on for five months.
Three second interval data.
Wow, we got a bite on
it too, look at this.
Look at these deep chips.
- Whoa.
- Look at that, a lot of
rapid [INAUDIBLE] data here.
This is spanning one, two,
three, four, five days
of intensive diving.
And it just continues.
- Wow.
- Look at this.
- Wow, that's incredible.
- Oh, my god, look at this.
- This guy is active.
- So this is right up
until the tag popped off.
It's got the most intense
diving about here.
That's really cool.
We're in a spot where
[INAUDIBLE] diving
is really intense.
- Yeah.
- Look at this, day and night.
- Gold.
- You guys, this is gold
in the form of data.
- Although Otis is mainly
focusing on the oceanography
and measuring what's going
on underneath the surface
of the ocean, Otis can
also listen for tags
that are in different species.
So we can kind of use Otis as a
sentinel underneath the ocean,
spying on who's down there for
us, while we're up on the ship
doing all the other
amazing science.
- The high seas covers
almost half this planet.
And in the high seas,
there are very few rules.
It's almost a Wild West.
So if we're going to
save white sharks,
and other iconic animals, such
as tunas, and other sharks,
for the next generation,
we have to start
thinking about where the
boundaries should be,
where the protection should be.
This cruise is
actually a beginning
in which we're going
to go out, offer
the opportunity for policy
changes that protect a region,
that no one would
think about needs
protection for white sharks.
Through new knowledge, we
can reduce ignorance and then
translate that into action.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHIEL BAKKER: All right,
and I think with that,
we're at the top of the hour.
I want to thank you very
much for your participation
and for, frankly, being here.
The audience, for
spending an hour with us.
And I think to be
continued, there's
a lot of work to be done.
Thank you very much.
ANA BLANCO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]